so thirty years ago after I went broke I
started studying how to handle money
studying what the Bible said about money
because I was a new thing to me I was a
new Christian I was a baby Christian I
met God on the way up I got to know him
on the way down and so I thought I
better find out what his love letter to
me says about money and what it says
about everything else for that matter
but I started studying what the Bible
says about money and I started talking
to old rich people to ask them how to
handle money now I didn't want to talk
to young rich people I'd been him and I
didn't want his opinion old people that
had made money and kept money that's who
I wanted to talk to I didn't want
get-rich-quick I had already been down
that road and lost everything I was a
millionaire by the time I was 26 and
then broke by the time I was 28 and
bankrupt with a brand-new baby and
marriage hanging on by a thread and a
new toddler so I started coaching people
and I would show them exactly what to do
I would lay out their budget with them I
would sit and talk to them and coach
them and say this is what we do I would
call their creditors and get the deal
set up so that they could pay the
payments we lay out the budget it
balanced all they had to do home is go
home and do it and they didn't do it I'd
run into them six weeks later how you
doing man I figure they're gonna be
doing great thing we found bankruptcy
you file bankruptcy why I just showed
you what to do I got really frustrated
so I started studying in the field of
counseling I'm not a professional
counselor but I started studying in that
field and saying okay what is working to
cause people to win because I start
figuring out it's not an information
problem it's an information and
inspiration problem personal finances
80% behavior it's only 20% of head
knowledge and so then we put together a
little class and I start teaching it
with an overhead projector in a bad suit
that little class later become known
became known as Financial Peace
University and when I first started
coaching people and started the class I
was just saying get out of debt
first thing you do should get out of
that before you do anything else you got
to get out of that because if you don't
have any payments you're gonna have
money to save money to invest money to
give you got to get out of debt they're
winning baby steps baby step was get out
of debt and then save and invest that
was the baby steps well when do I do
this well when do I do that well when do
I do there's a window I do that all
these questions kept coming up coming up
coming up and so I said well first step
is we're gonna pay off all the debt
except the house and we're gonna use the
debt snowball that's the first step well
then I would have people get halfway
through their baby step what we now call
baby step to get halfway through their
debt snowball and you know a hot water
heater would go out in the house and
they're like we don't have the money to
fix the hot water heater so we're going
in that well you're trying to get out of
that you can't get out of a hole while
you're digging out the bottom so that
didn't work so we added a baby step
there when we started calling them the
baby steps because we started realizing
people if they're gonna change behaviors
need to see a clearer path and it has
worked astronomically over five million
people through Financial Peace
University now millions and millions of
you listening over six million total
money makeover books sold all about the
baby steps and baby step one as you know
is to save $1,000 baby step two that's
your starter beginner emergency fund I
didn't used to have that on there but
you need that little bit of pad in case
something small happens you don't lose
hope and fall off the wagon and walk
away from the whole thing in
disappointment you don't throw up your
hands and go well I tried that is the
oven it didn't work now you can just fix
that one thing and then there we go
right and then you get back to it
thousand dollars baby step one starter
emergency fund then once you've done
that and you should do that like in a
month have a garage sale pull money out
of savings whatever you do immediately
put $1,000 then you say then you start
your debt snowball and that's listing
your debts everything but your house
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one attack
the little one work your way right down
that list
you see you shouldn't have to live
paycheck to paycheck you work too hard
to be broke and you don't have to and I
know some of you made some mistakes
we'll solve I I've got a PhD in D um B
that's what qualifies me to teach this
show I've done every stupid thing you
can do but that started noticing the
stupid things and I quit doing them and
the fewer stupid things I do the
wealthier I get when it comes to money
hello if your stupid things I do in any
area of my life the better that area
gets hello winners never quit yes they
do they quit doing stupid stuff pretty
regularly you find stupid stuff and you
stop doing it stuff that's not working
in your life stop doing it and you've
heard me talk about these seven baby
steps for decades now they work every
time for everyone now here's what's
happened see I've been doing this so
long that we've had it usually takes
about a month to do baby step $1,000
baby step two most people do in eighteen
to twenty-four months
so in under two years almost everyone is
debt free except their home now you may
have an exception but almost everyone's
debt free except their home if they get
after it with ghazal intensity and focus
and deep sacrifice then it takes about
another three or four months to finish
off your emergency fund and then you're
on the baby that's maybe step three or
three to six months of expenses then
you're on the start savings fifteen
percent of your income in the retirement
starts your kids college and then you
start working to pay your house off now
what's happening is all these years
later millionaires are popping up
everywhere and we start doing a
millionaire theme hour and then it got
us intrigued and so we had an outside
research firm to research non Dave
millionaires meaning people that have
not followed me and we used that same
research structure which was a detailed
you know properly done research project
to study Dave millionaires meaning
people that do know who I am and follow
me and give me some of the credit for
them being a millionaire in other words
a hot little I didn't do it they did it
and now we finished the largest study on
millionaires ever done over ten thousand
millionaires and the number one thing
they agreed on was getting out and
staying out of debt
our research shows that the vast
majority of millionaires never had a
penny of credit-card debt and if they
did they hadn't used a credit card
hadn't carried a balance on a credit
card in decades most of them never had a
car loan or if they did it was in their
early twenties and they got rid of it
they never borrow money for family and
friends they never took out student
loans and they live on less than they
make so if you're willing to do the work
you follow the stuff we teach you don't
need the government to produce a living
wage for you you get your butt out there
and work get up leave the cave kill
something and drag it home socialism has
never caused people to prosper and the
living wage movement is a socialism
movement so Dave I'm living proof you
can come from a poor family with a
terrible money habits and win out one
and a half million dollar net worth
they've been a single mom for 27 years
I've built my wealth almost all during
that time and million-dollar net worth
Financial Peace University is right now
on sale for 20% off and you can get the
every day millionaire book included on
pre-sale so you need to check both of
these out this causes all of this to
happen every day millionaire is how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can - and Financial
Peace University all on sale right now
at Dave Ramsey com